um hi everyone hi everyone this is your
boy psychobabble here um with Donald
Trump let me just change as a parallel
quick I know you want to see him what is
all this [ __ ] I got Oh like you're hard
okay okay um yeah so so meet me at the
hop right here and we're gonna do look
quest called them here kitty kitty and
we're fighting ashes for a little girl
in vol to anyone so let's just do this
okay enough with all this nonsense
that's a nice look at you in there a
little poor for my face looks like South
Jersey to me but you know something like
that something like that okay okay I get
it where's his kitty here is his caddy
oh [ __ ] I hate these things they just
they just rub it on her way you know
that's it yeah good let's get the [ __ ]
out me oh I hear [ __ ] vaporize that
[ __ ] you know no Sam you know what I'm
saying [ __ ] I gotta get rid of dude [ __ ]
okay get cat out okay good and uh just
got gut gut oh you got that he's not
that he's dead now okay okay let's do
this let's do this why did that mini
nuke Explo thats weird i care we gotta
find kid a UH is that kitty banging on
the door oh what the hell sad how we're
vaporize it betch okay I'll talk to
Aaron and Walt editor okay I'm gone
there and go there hey I ain't ain't
Lamba I gave Pompeii get bobbi and I get
poppy I ok ok that said let's do this
have to hang a call this long ass away
JS s takes like an hour to get in here I
got [ __ ] sit down Calvin's always
looking for tools good to be a regular
okay and I'm here I'm here okay thanks
for the welcome should hit the mic he
got by screaming your ears are bleeding
uh-huh Strine huh hey what strong hold
up strong change body strong thank you
good eater this okay Hank yeah and I
yeah Austin got himself a bow so now
they got his cooped up in here to watch
everything uh what are you looking you
look like you're like paranoid yeah okay
welcome I'm so chop is so nice hey Laz
isn't is it over
she's looking pretty bad no I don't like
I'm what's left here thanks for watching
guys thank you thank
you